ho appena finito di montare questo video
che state per vedere dal portatile con
te alla pesca di fianco quindi youtuber
4 milioni di iscritti e volevo
semplicemente dirvi che questa estate
per vedere visto che molti quello sono
io colpa nonino
molti mi richiedono spesso rocket league
allora ho registrato una sessione di
gioco con i miei amici e niente spero vi
piaccia mai fatto gol
dove ci hanno creduto mitra in mezzo
oddio ma serve tutti siete tutti
rino citati della madonna mai dai una
merda fai schifo
fai cagare vuoi giocare ai pokémon
pericoli e noi che siamo scarsi con una
morte ma perché dopo che ci parliamo in
questi dai per cortesia e poi fra il
serio paolo ii gol madonna come richiamo
mammamia dai che come faccio io volevo
assegnare almeno una volta prevedere la
nuova esclusione ma sarebbe stato
francese che mondiali del 2006
dobbiamo spalmare la parola materazzi se
segniamo ok ma io come l'ho mai ghadry
vantaggi tiro di qua no perché nella
torta o importatore e cucino io
qua che di un segnale forte del grande
paolo hayama cretino
sono forme da in mezzo ma non l'ho
trovato
666 tira tira da tiranno che sono loro
come facciamo a tirare occhio regali
così attaccano forte parla come tra gli
80 e vado nello spettro ma che più ha
fatto quella dove dall'inizi madonna
incredibile ma tutti in assurdo pro ii
lo farà tappa in mezzo poi vediamo
sono tutto ma donasse sono forti quindi
ecco ciò che non sa questo gioco ma che
casino i dipinti fortuna in gorla tira
tira tira a campare
porca vacca gravissimo mani ancora nutre
mezzo potrebbe essere la localizz stesso
team in carica sono anche più non è
affatto vero
caino e abele torni ci arrivano gaga
raga 15 secondi o aiuto aiuto hanno
paura ma occhio che ce lo dirà ma scarsi
a trasmetti di spingermi che palle e
milan è mila è di un'altra volta dai
pensieri e banca romana
vai vai
magari solo vita e tu vai a cagare
staccata quando io oraria occhio dell
impero dell'hot a marzo dalmazzo bravo
bravo bravo così ti voglio così così vai
perciò scusa ha tentato di è però non
c'è un tubolare spinta di prodotto
attenzione 2 brevissimo
insegniamo risparmiamo intorno a cosa
fatta di ormai buono ma può stare la
tira occhio occhio napoli continua
montino vai paolo continua continua
tirava lo dirà
ci sono ci sono la shueisha non ci sono
dove sono nata a un anatema lasciato
pure io non deve sconvolti occhio fare
niente non tifa scavalcano tifa scola
martin toro su uno schermo di non solo
di club ha rimandato occhio che questo e
combattutissima francia italia raga
magari solo uno che sa fare un centrale
in mezzo a tutti occhio perché la giochi
per gli altri su ma dai è venduto la
partita calciopoli ci sono è vero
materazzi pacchetto le palestre palestra
virtuale ed inter materazzi in vaghe
l'invito reciso però una ragazza che era
benvenuta bene bisognano finisco video
non ha accettato neanche il cestino
dell'immondizia che già aveva un metro
figurati se vinciamo la partita partendo
stiamo partendo capital fiasco secondo
me diciamo
allora se uno si chiama capitan fiasco
dall'altra parte secondo me possiamo
vincere che di questo ci sono la
drammaticità bene molti mezzo occhio
ma di ungaretti
grazie ragazzi tutto fiasco e piccole si
saranno è bello capitano piasco pad e
scialli che ci sono elettori e non
potevo fare mario paolo non ce n'è non
ce n'è non ce ne abbiamo paolo occhio e
paola vedo in mezzo avuti messo io mi è
piaciuto questo cross di toni faccio se
vuoi dai per favore che non l'ho visto
che ci mette i soldi e va bene però si
bravissimo ma che gold stava uscendo
tutto calcolato tutto volume
entra
ed è colpa mia però ma darà anche con
l'ha fatto quando vai vai a dubbio
gigi non l'ho presa prove occhio
madonna cosa ho fatto leggere stavano un
po troppo ma dov'è no mi decido io avevo
fatto
bye bye ha fatto le cose belle vai
parlavano paolo paolo ma dato che io
nella merda invece sta di mezzo qualcuno
importa ceo
una donna non ha bello e
figurati se entrava affidamento e mezzo
è stato la debutto su bravo dolce misura
no no trovo senza turbo va bene
continua non avere più limiti settimana
spinge a loro ragazzina allora buona
guardavano stavolta disegno di sarà
toccata riparte neeson visto che vengo a
me è piaciuto a chi oggi occhio che cosa
ho fatto
ma da madonna de gaulle che gol
incredibile ma che grossi li bel gol di
dani fantasticare su pain piacete
fortissimi nell italia l'incredibile
contro la leggenda tra l'altro che
andrea dei bumper occhio grande andrea e
si buttano subito la sua e mezzo in
mezzo c'è il tipo greco melo in spinto
malissimo occhio paolo paolo paolo ii
nella impresa male ma vera vita voglio
di nuovo
bravi come pacate gli host a 3 a 1 dello
spacco io bye bye così vai così facendo
2 2
clamoroso no no
calmo lì per uno attenzione l'ultimo
tiro
basta lo lasciava cadere perfetto
madonna cosa abbia portato come capita
che gli stati bravissimi
grazie grazie e questa era rocket lidi
ragazzi e quello sono sempre io col
pannolino però che vi dispiace ragazzi
comaschi preciso momento mi piace anche
una competizione dove siete e noi
cerchiamo a un prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]